the Joe Rogan experience that's a hard
thing for me to not do something because
if I'm not if I'm awake and I'm not
occupied my thoughts are just going so
like that's something else I've been
doing I mean I've started to write
things down I've been doing like some
stunt work acting all right so I've been
lately I've been watching old shows and
and just watching it for the acting and
and I'll find a script and I'll stand in
front of mirror by myself and do some
things like I'm just like I'm just I'm
just going through all of it I uh I did
I did I did a small move they're doing a
movie about Nick Newell right and I I so
I fight the character guy that's playing
Nick Newell and one scene early in his
career Nick Knowles the fighter was one
on one our does the guy in the movie
have one arm as well no but he did
green-screen it oh so so he's he's the
whole time he has his green sleeve over
his arm and he has it out here and he's
moving it and we have we choreograph the
fight and we have to kind of attract out
for all of that in the choreography with
the green-screen all that although but I
got a couple lines did some lines and
the first time I did lines with Kevin
Pollak so I was cool wow you know that's
pretty crazy
yeah and then um and then I did an
episode abolish for the next season so
that was cool did you work with the rock
no I worked with Ricky so so JD
Washington okay so that was cool and I
had met I didn't I didn't I watched
these shows I didn't know his name was
JD wash I just knew his name was JD from
being on set I always called him Ricky I
was there somebody told me he was
related to Denzel Washington and then I
find out that his last name is
Washington when I'm on set and I'm
looking at the call sheet and I'm like
hey you ladies Denzel and he's like yeah
he has his look on his face like [ __ ]
you know you know that and I like I knew
he was related but I thought he would
tell me how at the time and I don't know
but I later I found out that it was his
dad oh no [ __ ] is is that you know some
from what the information that I've got
oh and um so but but and I had met his
dad also work with him on equalizer we
were for the equalizer too we were we
were
helping him build the scenes we
choreographing the scenes and teaching
in the choreography for that and I have
this disarm this thing where he's giving
me voice lessons I have this thing with
Denzel Washington giving me voice
lessons I'm sure like he's you know
these these these tongue twisters that
he says to practice enunciate
oh you know it's kind of dope so so
wearing in the gym we're working out and
he's like so he tell he says them to me
and he's like you should write this down
because my buddy tells me yeah he does
stuff on fought on the Fox test for UFC
and so he's like he pays a little more
attention to me at that point he's like
yeah he's going back to theater he wants
to do some theater cuz he wants to clean
up his stuff and so he's like you should
write this down I'm like look [ __ ] I
grabbed my phone and I start recording
and then he sees that I'm recording so
he comes over and he's like he's
speaking into my phone and I'm like I
have this [ __ ] off I have this one
Denzel Washington voice coaching me
super dope right
[Applause]